[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy happy happy hump day
give a cheer to democracy
not placate to putin
[Music]
we really do have some [ __ ] to sort out
in this country when we have mike pompeo
the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants
and
and also we have tucker carlson
getting on their knees and servicing the
bladdy daddy vladimir putin
well
i thought we were for democracy in this
country but
it seems as if it seems as if there are
some
who are not
who are not for democracy
who would rather stand with vladimir
putin
than to stand for the safety of the
american and allied troops
including the troops in ukraine
it really does says something when the
gqp
is all but backing i mean they are
backing at this point
jesus christ russian state tv is
blasting mike pompeo and tucker could
carlson clips over and over and over and
over again
it really does say something about the
party of trump
so who's going to stand with america
in the gqp
none of them
we have some clips to show you of course
of course we do
there's plenty of clips of these morons
giving fellatio to vladimir putin
the best part
is we may
gabe gabe may have booked
a a murderous dictator for our guest
today
if you catch my drift
we'll see
we'll see if we can get someone on the
horn
so
other news today
so far
so far
you know because
you can't not have news
we have on the [ __ ] list we have thanks
joe biden and the keystone pipeline
because you know
we have to reopen something that was
never open
and that way it can be finished so that
way it can lower
the price of fuel for their
overly sized
small dick energy trucks
i mean that's the that's the thread
uh martin hyde i've never heard of this
[ __ ] apparently martin hyde he's a
congressional candidate who's backed by
roger stone and he was pulled over
pulled over by the police
doing uh i think it was
57 and a 40 i believe he was speeding
and he was texting and he's an [ __ ]
of course he's a white privileged
[ __ ]
and he gets the treatment of white
privilege in the stop
as he's smart-mouthing the police you
know back the blue and all that sort of
thing
[ __ ] break uh cbs news is trending as
well as west point because that's where
the traitor pompeo
went
some people are saying west point should
pull his [ __ ] degree
we also have news that the national
guard is probably going to be deployed
for the trucker convoy of dc
the trucker insurrection as we may have
to come to call it
jesus [ __ ] christ
all all in the l in the guise of
anti-democracy
it's not it's not anti-vaxx
at this point it's not anti-vaxx it's
it's to show people who want
who want fascism
that hey we can convince people that
democracy bad and if we can convince
people that democracy bad then people
like putin will remain in power
why do you think we're doing what we're
doing here
that all around the world there's these
little pockets of anti-democracy
of fascism
because putin wants to make sure that
people in this world
doubt that democracy works
if he can so doubt maybe he can remain
in power
there's a pattern with tyrants
and there's an ultimate
ending to tyrants
all of them
every [ __ ] last one of them
they end up in a hole in a bunker
they end up either being executed or at
the end of the rope
putin knows this he's not [ __ ] dumb
he's terrified jesus have you seen him
he won't even come within 60 feet of
another human being he's so [ __ ]
paranoid
so paranoid and scared of the virus
coronavirus that is which he's probably
quadruple vast
at this point
it really is
it really is getting really really
really really hard
hard to believe that anyone who
associates themselves with the
republican party the gqp
as pro-democracy at all
like even just a little bit
you should see the clips
of tucker carlson on fox news
basically saying
you have to support putin because putin
good joe biden bad
so forget about american troops forget
about the american military forget about
our constitution
forget about all that
all that does not
matter
democracy bad so the alternative must be
good
and by the way they so doubt in this
country by saying we're not even a
democracy we're republic
making people question it even more
it really is
it really is a very disturbing sad day
in this country
when the words of
former leaders
and one of the most watched cable new
hosts
in this country
in america and those two people claim to
be patriots and for america and four
american soldiers
to be used as propaganda over and over
and over on russian state tv
if
we continue down this road
and let these people take over parts of
our government we have this martin hyde
who claims
who claims to be
a patriot probably
being pulled over by the police
basically
demeaning the police officer that pulls
him over
but this is the attitude
this is the entitlement this is the
privilege
and they think it's okay
let's not waste much more time
let's start the countdown and get to the
shitless roundup
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
welcome to the shitless roundup where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends of today let's start off
with the timeline here um there's a few
things i want to get to a few of these
uh
a few of these
clips
of the putin's puppies that we have uh
gabe says here grand old putin
ain't that about the truth g.o.p grand
old putin
hmm
their party is now putin
uh mayo says republicans are traitors to
democracy in america hashtag traitors to
democracy that's a a hashtag going
around
traitors to democracy i think it fits
just perfect with the gqp and these
republican [ __ ]
i said picking putin over america makes
traders
traitors to democracy
you have to have to have to stop
putin
from infiltrating the minds
of pro-democracy people and how do we do
that we send a message
and one of the messages is
traitors to democracy
speaking of complete utter nonsense
going on and on about putin and how
putin's a tough guy
we have thanks joe biden trending
because
you know
the gqp and their sheep don't understand
how gasoline prices work aaron here says
167 dollars to fill up my truck today in
arcadia thanks joe biden
obviously people are making big [ __ ]
jokes
about
their big trucks and their big gasoline
bills
like
this is this is this the same [ __ ]
nonsense
as this i can't get a whopper
because i don't have a vaccine card
you chose
you
chose that vehicle
right and they always want to post the
amount that they're paying overall and
i'm not saying gas isn't high
i'm not saying that at all
i mean under every president gasoline
prices fluctuate up and down and at some
point in their presidency gas is
considered high
and there's a reason for that let's go
down here
let me see if i can find here it is
uh midas kim reposted this said thanks
joe biden for doing what you can to
bring down gas prices
thanks joe biden
i say thanks brandon in our little in
our little clip
but here is politics girl
psy let's do this again
so let's watch this video
she always does a great job now this was
back at the end of the year but it's
still a prize because this is how fuel
prices work let's listen so people are
mad about gas prices and like every
president before him biden is taking the
hit here's the skinny on what happened
starting around the spring of 2020 when
we were locked down working from home
not traveling or going anywhere because
of the pandemic the demand for gas
dropped dramatically so american oil
producers dropped drilling dramatically
and when they did that they laid off a
ton of people the companies say they
fired all these workers to just try and
stay alive but since gas companies make
obscene profits receive billions of
dollars in government subsidies and even
if they were in trouble which they
weren't we had two bailouts to make sure
businesses like theirs didn't go under
it wasn't about trying to stay alive but
more about trying to keep their profits
high and their bonuses flush but now
that people are back to driving and
traveling these same companies are
taking their sweet time to ramp up
industry because less product means
higher prices and they are making killer
profits because of it in fact the oil
and gas industry is making more money
now than they were before the pandemic
they have leases on 23 million acres of
puck land they aren't using almost 10
000 permits to drill but they aren't
drilling they aren't spending profits to
hire back their employees or make their
businesses more efficient they're
spending it on shareholder buybacks
instead the bottom line is oil companies
would rather raise prices than increase
supply now we could get our gas from
somewhere else but opec the organization
that controls the oil in the rest of the
world won't sell it to us because
they're doing exactly the same thing
restricting the amount of product that
goes into the market so the prices stay
high and they can recoup the profits
they lost during the pandemic the
problem isn't biden the problem is greed
remember these are the same companies
that hid the research and said they were
causing catastrophic climate change for
40 years and bought up all electric
vehicle patents so they couldn't be made
these are not good people these are good
businessmen president biden might not
have much power over this industry but
what he does have he's using he signed
an executive order for the department of
energy to release 50 million barrels of
oil from the strategic reserve to help
lower the cost of gas he coordinated
that effort with other large nations to
do the same he publicly called out opec
for holding back the supply and he also
asked the ftc to consider whether the
oil and gas industry is engaging in any
potentially illegal and anti-competitive
behavior making prices higher for the
american consumer and lo and behold
crude oil prices started coming down hmm
funny that so people can keep putting
the biden i did that sticker on gas
pumps across america but it only shows
how little they know about who the real
villain here is and it's not the
president as usual it's corporate grade
the what
at the end
uh politics girl
giving her take again
on gas prices uh
this is again this is [ __ ]
not rocket science it really isn't
about how gas prices work it's never
been
a secret
of how gas prices work especially during
fluctuations of supply and demand
that's that's the key
that's the key here's
thanks joe biden for not being putin's
[ __ ]
make treason greater grin you got the
number wrong here it should be 20 22.
maybe even 20 24 i don't know maybe 20
30 you know who knows how many times
this [ __ ] gonna
think he's gonna run
uh it depends on if he can get his true
social uh account up or not did you guys
did you guys see the truth social uh
completely [ __ ] flopped yeah and i
know you know maybe maybe just maybe by
march or so uh they'll have the means to
get it up and running now this this this
poster 573 dollars to fill up my tricked
out semi that no one told me to buy
thanks joe biden
thanks brandon
thanks brandon
christ
and this is this is the the [ __ ] that
they have
right they go through and they're like
oh
i i went up to fill my truck it's got
huge tires it's way over done it's
ridiculous it gets two miles to the
gallon
and joe biden is causing me to fill it
up
what you chose that [ __ ]
is really dumb
uh let's see
and
this looks like a fun one
uh 543 to fill up my ride but jet fuel
cost a little more thanks joe biden
god damn it i gotta get to work
cost
543 dollars to get to work
what else we got going here
of course the thanks joe biden uh the
thread here
works really good this must be um this
must be the original thing that set this
off
again
this guy congressman greg stouby
hey scooby dooby where's he
florida's 17th
florida's 17th
and he's a gq peer
and he doesn't understand that when he
has a an arcadia
it could uh it could cost 167
to fill that [ __ ] up
yeah when you have a big ass [ __ ]
truck with a big ass [ __ ] gas tank
with really shitty gas mileage
it's gonna cost you some change
doesn't matter what the [ __ ] the dollar
per gallon is
it really doesn't
i mean you see here on the gauge a
hundred and sixty set well you you
bought 44
gallons of fuel
now
most most cars
trucks
suvs if they have one tank most times
however much gas that tank will hold
it's normally like 300 to 350 miles per
tank is what you get right if you fill
it up if it's [ __ ] empty you fill it
up you're gonna get 300 350 miles on
that tank
it doesn't matter if it's a truck a car
that's why
more economical cars they have smaller
gas tanks because they get better gas
mileage they don't need a big ass 44
gallon tank which is probably got a 50
000 or excuse me 50
a 50 gallon tank
to get this truck to do 300 350 miles
per fill up
of course everyone's calling saying that
gas is six bucks a gallon like you know
oh it's six bucks it's seven bucks a
gallon it's killing me you know well the
congressman greg here forgot to cut that
part
out of his out of his little photo here
it's not six bucks a gallon
wherever he's buying this fuel for his
arcadia
thanks joe biden your [ __ ] tweet
sucks dude
of course twitter's gonna want to censor
see every time
every time your tweet sucks welcome to
the shitless roundup greg you [ __ ] okay
i think that was the uh the original
yeah this is the original [ __ ] tweet
that caused this thanks joe biden trend
uh mayo said thanks joe biden for
standing up to putin and kicking trump's
ass
taking him behind the woodshed and
spanking his ass by the way
everyone mayo is back i don't know if
you guys know that her original account
mayo is spicy is back
it
do let's see what else thanks joe biden
do we have see see again this is the
this is the [ __ ]
see how they got six dollars
that's got to be [ __ ]
it's
it's [ __ ]
photoshopped give me a [ __ ] break
what the [ __ ] is this
thanks joe biden for never stealing
jill's look
oh
[ __ ]
how have i never seen this one oh [ __ ]
i'm posting that
and for you
listening uh melania's trump is standing
here with a white brimmed hat and a
white suit uh macron and
his wife
are next to them and donald trump is
wearing the same thing melania is
um
let's see here
what do we have in the thanks joe biden
well you know we we do a commercial here
that says thanks joe we do we do little
videos thanks brandon because you know
they're little the let's go brandon
nazis they couldn't say [ __ ] joe biden
so i mocked them
and say you know give up whatever the
good news is like in january it was the
job numbers
that joe biden has created more jobs
than any other president in his
term of office up to this point
and frankly that's how democrats do it
republicans don't create jobs
republicans destroy jobs
that's what they do they kill the
economy [ __ ] they want to do it right
now they're encouraging
they're encouraging a trucker's convoy
to dc
because they want to have a trucker's
insurrection or some [ __ ]
i don't know
okay um looks like we got a new topic
trending here
tori what's this
i have a lot of time and respect
for luke
pollard shadow minister armed forces
labor mp oh this is uh
this seems like it's in the uk
uk politics here trending in the united
states
um it looks like
they're going they're
talking about russian interference of
course with russia in the news
that's going to be a hot topic anywhere
around the world is how putin's trying
to interfere in elections how putin's
trying to uh spread his anti-democracy
message around the world by getting
fascist
well in any means necessary really i
mean putin doesn't really give a [ __ ] if
it's fascists that help him if it's
leftists that help him if it's moderates
if it's racist if it's neo-nazis he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
who's gonna help him spread his
anti-democracy message here
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
uh let's see
what is there anything
is there a good video
of that
uh and tori
because
some of these videos that come out of
the uk parliament
are [ __ ] fantastic
they're just like
at each other's
roots
just dunking on each other
doesn't look like we have video yet of
their arguments
in the parliament and against uh russian
interference let's see let's go down a
little further
i want to get to this uh we're 26
minutes into the hour i think our
special guest
pompeo putin uh excuse me pompeo's
bestie
maybe joining us soon
uh let's see
we wanted to
oh the national guard story there that's
what we were talking about truckers
convoy uh the pentagon has okayed
national guard deployment to dc ahead of
the truckers convoy
let's give that credit
and then scott has a report here
uh alert secretary of defense has
approved requests for the dc and the u.s
capitol police for district of columbia
national guard assistance
with traffic control during first
amendment demonstrations
expected in the district in the coming
days as truck convoys are expected i
love i love the uh
this is the first amendment demonstrate
i think that's i think that's in lead up
to
insurrection because that's what they're
going to try to do they're going to try
to shut down the economy quote unquote
so that way they can shut down the
government like they were doing ottawa
just same [ __ ] thing
same spreading doubt about democracy
getting people to try to overturn
democracy by having a few
decide they're gonna shut down and
change the entire country's policy on
one issue
and really honestly it's a little
[ __ ] weird in canada
because justin trudeau which
again you talk about [ __ ] weird
situations they call him
canada's putin
well you think you'd love him then
you think you love trudeau if he's like
putin and he's really protecting and
he's he's gonna be nice and a peacemaker
on the border and that what [ __ ]
grandpa poopy pants said about his
boyfriend over in russia and [ __ ]
but here we have the national guard
being deployed or ready to be deployed
to stop another insurrection
well looks like they're doing the job
that they should have done
on january 6th
and being ready
for the worst for our democracy it
really is funny how
uh these people are bitching about the
gas prices but they're all going to
drive their [ __ ] semi trucks to dc
and let them sit and run
and run
and run and burn more and more and more
fuel just sitting idle
in protest
thanks joe biden
uh occupied democrats as breaking news
the national guard announces that two of
trump's january six insurrectionists are
still serving in the national guard
now that's maybe some news
outside of them being deployed
could cause problems
because they're being protected by the
wisconsin virginia state guards which
refused to repeal them
uh looks like there's
virginia you know each state has the
national guard then you have the the dc
national guard
but uh in which the president united
states
has some authority over
you
[Music]
national guardsmen being insurrectionist
hmm
seems like a really big deal
let's see what else do we have in this
what else do we have in this national
guard thread we're 30 minutes into the
hour here uh if if if we have a guest
joining us they should be joining us
soon so let's go
let's go take a look at the pompeo
thread
why we're thinking of it
um it was here
this you know oh here see greg abbott's
now trending at number two
i wonder i wonder how much fellatio greg
abbott is giving putin to trend at
number two that's what you gotta wonder
here's pompeo
yeah you guys know the treacherous
treason as [ __ ]
mike pompeo um he was doing a little uh
dance with putin on
um i forget whose show it is here it is
is this it
uh no that's something different this is
it
it was uh but they're playing it on
russian state tv
where he's basically giving fellatio to
vladimir putin and that's why they want
to play it and if i can find it here
we'll play it
let's go to videos
see that
i always forget that if you want to go
to just videos you just click the video
tab
dummy
well maybe
there we go
let's see if we can find this clip
this
[ __ ]
putin's puppy his little boyfriend
vladimir putin and
mike pompeo go on a date
what is this [ __ ] bill o'reilly
does he have a [ __ ] tv show
does he no
let's see that's not it
we're gonna find it here
as we're waiting for our guests to
come on
uh
well here it is
no
no that's not it
that's there there it is ah-ha
we found it
we
found it
it's about 45 seconds uh apparently this
is let's see
i think this is the one that they're
blasting
all over russian state tv
propaganda
uh no i i consider him a
elegantly sophisticated
counterpart
and one who is not reckless but has
always done the math
and we may disagree with his priorities
we may disagree with his math
we certainly disagree that the interests
that he seeks are reasonable for his
country many cases
but we should never underestimate that
he is he is doing this in a way where he
is exhibiting his capacity to control
and his deep desire that he is most
important objective and i should have
listed this first his most important
objective is that he continues to run
the deal
first and foremost he is about power for
himself making sure that his place as
the leader of russia continues
i don't think that's the clip
we'll give credit here for showing this
i don't think that's the
clip he was
quoted saying something
here
enormous respect there we go here it is
very true
very careful i have enormous respect for
him i've been criticized for saying that
um
i have enormous respect i have enormous
respect for him
and they keep playing this over and over
and over and over again
over and over and over again on russian
state tv
and the reason why is because it it
shows that oh look a former secretary of
state look he backs putin why wouldn't
the russian people back putin america's
behind putin look the former american
president
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopypants
himself he's behind putin
mike pompeo he's behind putin and oh
yeah
oh yeah
tucker carlson
tucker [ __ ] carlson
one of the most watched fascist on tv
it'd be worth asking yourself since it
is getting pretty serious what is this
really about why do i hate putin so much
has putin never called me a racist has
he threatened to get me fired for
disagreeing with him has he shipped
every middle class job in my town to
russia did he manufacture a worldwide
pandemic that wrecked my business and
kept me indoors for two years is he
teaching my children to embrace racial
discrimination
is he making fentanyl is he trying to
snuff out christianity does he eat dogs
what these are fair questions and the
answer to all of it is no vladimir putin
didn't do any of that
okay well we got a guest on our show
here
and uh let's see if we can bring them in
um gabe booked this guest for us
let's see if we can
hello sir how are you i heard we got a
uh
a nice guest here how are you
uh sir sir
are you
putin i i i believe this is vlad
vladimir putin
comment um okay
yep
yep
yep quiet
okay
uh sir can i ask you a question
at we we can't we can't hear you we
can't hear you we can't hear you
we we we can't we can't hear you you're
you're mike you're mike
you're mike
it see this is the thing is right
wingers have no idea how to run tech and
definitely for sure the russians have no
clue how to run their microphone
absolutely no clue
can you hear me now sir
i can't i can't hear you
we'll we'll bring him
putin get your mic straight and then
we'll bring you back okay
you got it can you handle the mic over
there putin
uh vladimir putin trying to come on the
show without having his mic ready the
[ __ ] okay let's let's go back
to tucker's questions here maybe maybe
we'll be able to ask uh blatty about his
uh these questions that tucker has for
two years is he teaching my children to
embrace racial discrimination is he
making fentanyl is he trying to snuff
out christianity does he eat dogs does
he eat dogs let's see if we can bring
up
putin
oh for [ __ ] sake
turn that [ __ ] off
hey hey turn that [ __ ] [ __ ] off
i'm gonna mute this son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
bladdy
blatty
blatty
[Music]
can i ask you a question sir
no for [ __ ] sake this [ __ ] guy
hey you [ __ ] bonehead turn the
[ __ ] music off
[Music]
[Applause]
are you done are you done
hello finished
can you can you answer questions now
yes i've had my moment to enjoy greatest
music ever
greatest greatest music ever huh yes
yeah well
some would disagree
so let me ask you putin
what's your goal in ukraine
ukraine is property of russia we own it
it was russia it is russia right so it's
stamped russian it sounds like you want
to go back to the old days of the uh the
ussr is that is that wrong with ussr
back in the ussr we are back back back
in the ussr you know beetles beetles are
great they're great yeah they're great i
know they're not bothered before little
guys from uh from the uk
so what what is so important about your
property of the ukraine is it because
they're a democracy and you hate [ __ ]
democracy is that what it is democracy
issues democracy is not good okay it no
work
why doesn't it work
it doesn't work for who it doesn't work
for tyrants
democracy i decide everything oh is that
is that how democracy is the people
yeah okay all right well tucker carlson
here wanted to ask you a few questions i
was wondering if you could i'd love to
go with this last pretty nice boy he oh
yeah yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure when
you see him he'll give you
fellatio my face time last night it was
very good oh you did you did what was
said in your face time last night black
tell him you very good boy and he's like
thank you vlady and then i said
uh thank you little boy i pat you on
head on facetime camera
and then he's like thank you daddy
bloody daddy and i said please keep
calling me that
okay well um
fair enough let's let's go to one
question that uh tucker carlson here had
for you about christianity does he eat
dogs do you eat dogs what the [ __ ] does
that mean
he's little joke it's little joke no no
don't take so seriously don't um
get your pants up in a
toiti toiti you know
what
why would i be all hoity to i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] about it good for pet
dog good for dinner yes
so you eat dog
i don't know maybe
what do you mean maybe you don't know
you don't know what they feed you in
russia aren't you scared again make the
meal okay i tell my people
make meal they make the meal what's in
the meal i don't know but it tastes very
good it tastes very good so you don't
know if the poison tastes good or not i
know who said i was poisoning anybody i
i i you are you like poison did you say
that i poisoned somebody
did i say you poisoned somebody i mean
you did poison somebody
you ever heard of the uh character alexi
navalny do you know that name
never heard of him never at all
never heard of him
never
you don't have him in a prison in russia
but
that's that's not true that's that's big
poisoned him he went to germany he came
back you arrested him as soon as he came
across
tony tony mr tony montana it sounds like
no no not tony montana tony michaels yes
book show with tony montana
tony montana
right now okay i tell you right now do
you like cocaine speaking of tony
michaels do you like cocaine i like
winters i like going like
oh yeah yeah okay well you know
let's go back to some more questions
that tucker had for you here okay
ever called me a racist
has put never called me a racist have
you ever called putin or as has have you
ever called tucker carlson a reason i
don't um
i don't call him racist he don't call me
racist we are just two white guys having
good time
good time what kind of good time do you
like to have with tucker carlson what do
you what else are you doing on the uh
the face the face time the the zoom
calls we have very intimate um
intimate conversation no okay okay
bro
you know mm-hmm okay well let's go back
we pushed it out you know we just
feasted
okay well let's go back to another
question here stay on task here vladdy
daddy i know i know you love
her tucker carlson let's let's see what
other questions he has for you
has he threatened to get me fired for
disagreeing with him have you ever
threatened what would you like to do
why would i try to get him fired i love
that little guy huh mr tucker carlson
he's a very good person do you miss his
bow ties uh the bow ties were very nice
yes yeah do you do you wear bow ties
every once in a while i mean i know you
normally go shirtless unless you get a
little skin for the scene yeah people
like
people like
when i go hunting i go horseback riding
is very good yeah you know so you're
good at hunting and fishing or you're
just good at taking pictures that you're
good at hunting and fishing i'm good i'm
good
okay well let's let's go to um another
question here
has he shipped every middle-class job in
my town to russia
have you been taking middle-class jobs
from america okay listen i don't like
this accusation that people make about
us okay i'm trying to tell you right now
okay we love uh
we're not taking anything from anybody
okay
so nothing no lives no nothing no no
freedom no freedom do you believe in
freedom
i believe in i believe in freedom i
believe that people want something and i
decide for them what they want boom
i'm like god so you so you hand out
freedom for people
look okay i all i need to tell you right
now is i believe in freedom okay i have
freedom to do whatever i want and then
uh people say i want this and then i go
uh i decide for you
you decide for the people i decide the
hand of putin decides for the people no
i see i see i am
i am god you are a god to them is that
what you're saying i'm like that song
kanye west sing he's like i am a god you
are a guy how does it go how does it go
can you can you sing it
i am a god
that's how that's how it goes it's very
good yes okay let's try to get that
russian uh russian idol let's see what
what else tucker has questions for you
did he manufacture a worldwide pandemic
that wrecked my business and kept me
indoors for two years did you did you
create the coronavirus i did not that
was um
wuhan and that
far away from people because you're
terrified like i don't like german from
the poorest okay these poor people
i don't know what did you call poor
people what did you go about
the poor's the poor that's like i don't
i mean i mean my i mean my my office i
mean my mansion my castle i don't need
people getting near me you know even the
wet stuff i say put the dish put the
dish down 50 feet away
oh so you want them to stay 50 feet not
just not just six no eyes this
this skin this skin right here it cannot
get sick okay the skin can't get sick
what do you mean the skin can't get sick
i can't have people touching the putin
oh you people so the people the poor's
can't touch the putin look look look i
make it very simple for you tony montana
tony michaels yes tony montana i like
yes
yeah go guns blazing people yes i like
it no no that's that's not me that's
someone else it's a character i tell you
right now okay um
the russians and my people
love the putin they love the putin
who loves the your people are the people
that you oppress
the the people of russia the people i
love the people okay you know what let's
see what else
sometimes when i'm alone you know for
the you know show the skin for the scene
sometimes i put uh lotion on the skin
you put the lotion on the skin yes the
the i put the motion on the skin yes
okay well that sounds familiar let's
let's see what else uh questions tucker
has for you here is he teaching my
children to embrace racial
discrimination
do you teach
tucker carlson's children anything
i don't i don't know his children i
talked to i talked to tucker little boy
tucker he's very nice man but i have
never spoken to children you really you
really like tucker carlson he's great
he's great he's uh what makes him so
great because you guys play him on
russian tv like all the time oh yes he's
in very good uh very good at we we fist
each other you know you fist each other
yeah we're like boom boom we found each
other he's like found me bro and i'm
like go to pound town with tucker
carlson yeah well on the first time and
he says um
okay see you later vladi daddy and then
i say fist me bro fist fist you yeah
fist me come on now get deep in there
and fish me
this time you mean bump right no feast
pound it put me on the the face time put
the pound right in there yeah so you
want to go to pound town
with tucker carlson okay let's let's go
to another
americans call it huh let's go to
another question here is he making
fentanyl are you making fentanyl do you
mind i don't know about this fentanyl
okay people keep asking me about this
fentanyl [ __ ] okay i know nothing about
it okay you seem a little upset about
the flavor i don't make it okay look i
don't like this next question next
question no no no no no no i want any
questions i don't like these things
i've been out of shape about the
fentanyl thing look what you see a
fentanyl schminten okay look uh look
what is it i don't know okay
it's a drug that's killing thousands of
people why are you so being out of shape
about fentanyl because his accusation is
not true okay listen to tucker
listen to tucker carlson he says i don't
make fentanyl okay he said that yes
well yeah tucker lies a lot you know
that no no no no he's no lie he know why
he say truth all about me all the time
oh wait
okay look her buddy tony montana oh yeah
yeah yeah it's stony michaels but yeah
go ahead okay let's is he trying to
snuff out christianity are you trying to
snuff out christianity
why would i try to snuff out
christianity christianity is a great
religion
god god tell me i make decision for
russians and then boom i am god it is
great oh so you think in the christian
religion god anoints you god yes i one
night i was i was sleeping in my bed uh
very securely with the guards 50 feet
away that's out of my door right and
then what happened was um
this angel uh came to see me and said uh
i am bestowing on you the hand of god
and then i was i became god and now for
russians i decide what they want and
what they don't want what what was the
angel's name
the angel's name was um
it was gabriel the angel the archangel
gabriel yeah he came to me he said he
came to me and he said you are the
chosen one
he he called you the chosen one i have
quick meeting got to check email hold on
one moment yeah go ahead got to check
email okay
okay cool next question
enough about this fentanyl [ __ ] okay
what what was the email about
uh just someone i have to deal with
deal with what do you mean deal with
well it doesn't matter i say best
regards boot
what does that mean put sure for putin
people love poot huh they love the poot
they love the poot like like
tucker
loves the fist
yes he loves to fish huh he loves going
through as you said going to the pound
town with me and the pound not jesus
okay that blatty daddy what do you what
do you think about the former president
of the united states
are you guys are you guys in a romantic
relationship don't be humpy i love that
guy huh trump you call him trumpy humpy
look i call him yes we have many
nicknames for each other and he is
called trumpy jumpy okay trumpy
humpy that's what you're saying because
he has hump in in big stomach huh and he
hunches over like oh i got the hump you
know so i call him trumpy humpy but
here's what he here well i mean i i can
see what you say about him here's what
he said about you
i said he's smart is that how smart is
that the former us president continued
and he's going to go in and be a
peacekeeper do you consider yourself a
peacekeeper even though you're starting
wars i mean you're like
ukraine i go into ukraine i go into
other places in russia and i say well
here comes the peace is the hand of god
that is a peacekeeper huh god told me
the archangel gabriel told me that i was
a god and i am a peacekeeper
so you're a peacekeeper so the president
united states is is kind of agreeing
with the archangel gabriel there yes
you're right
i go into other places i say this is
mine this is mine this is part of russia
this is for the people this is for me
that's how i keep the peace
well he goes on to say he goes on to to
get on his knees for you and say we
could use that on our southern border um
that's the strong peace force i've ever
seen so he's saying that your army is
better than the american army yes yes
yeah yeah exactly how we practice it he
said you know perfectly you know yo just
so you wrote this for him i i gave him
suggestions edits as you people call it
you know i go in copyright you know i'm
a ghost writer in the background
but i give him suggestion but it sounds
very good very close to what i told him
so it's not exactly so what exactly did
you tell him to say
i told him that putin was great putin
was good for world putin will rule
america
putin will rule america you told him to
say that
yes he didn't say that it looks it looks
like
maybe maybe quote got cut off or he
might have uh stopped himself midway
through
but either way we will we will face time
tonight and i will correct that so next
time he goes on to show and discuss his
affairs with me
that uh he will get it right but putin
will rule america okay so he'll
eventually say that is what you're
saying yes get your point across he will
huh
point for putin point for putin the poot
huh yes in the poot yes
okay well he also says here
here's a guy who's very savvy do you
consider yourself do you know what the
word savvy means yes very smart very
smart very clever huh
you're yeah you refer to yourself in the
third person a lot do you do that all
the time
putin great
well the russians love the putin they
love they say grab me by the putin you
know
that's
are you scared of democracy are you
scared of democracy taking hold look
tony tony tony we try this democracy
okay we we try it it fail it no good we
go test run i say hey look look look i
am democracy i decide what people want
and then i give them what they want that
is all that's needed huh
so what you're saying
is that democracy is bad
look i'm not saying democracy is bad but
i say democracy is broken it no work
okay democracy's
what's broken about democracy other than
interfering in life everybody have say
everybody say i want this i want that
and then it's like who really wants what
they want so i decide like steve jobs i
just say i know what consumer wants okay
and i know what's best for a consumer
and consumer is russian and what i want
is best for what everybody wants
so you're so you're saying you're like
steve jobs and you want to be a
murderous dictator in russia look okay
enough with these accusations tony okay
i tell you right now okay i decide what
is best for russians and that is it
that's all that's
next question next question that's not
much fairer than democracy look look
look i don't know if you want to fish
this out later but i tell you right now
i'm not going to fist with you no no we
pounded we fisted no no no no we're not
getting time it's a good time huh no no
no no good time
one thing i do want to show you speaking
of someone uh fisting somebody here
yeah here is the former secretary of
state i know you love this guy too
probably got a good guy huh
no he's a piece of [ __ ] trader in this
country uh let's play what he said about
russia
very capable i have enormous respect for
him i've been criticized for saying that
uh
now i have enormous respect for him uh
he was also an interlocutor
that was
uh always well informed
and deeply clear about what russian
interests were i appreciate it i care
about russian interests i care about
what the people want they wait so is
russian enters your interest or is it
the russian people's okay i decide you
know i'm i'm a person who takes all of
these voices these little these little
annoying voices from people that say i
need this i need more water i need more
food i need more money you know i say so
they say that to you and you don't give
them that it's like do you need this i
don't know okay you know like boom boom
barbie do i hear voices anymore no
because
what is the bing bing bada boom thing
mean what does that mean
look look it just means what it means
okay i
that's what they say i am also
that is for the people that know spanish
it means um goodbye
adios means goodbye in spanish that is
correct so what are you saying goodbye
are you are you murdering them if
they're
these people these people complain to me
every single day and then i say bing
bing bing boom bye and then they leave
russia where do they go i don't care i
tell people to handle it and they handle
it for me well you know
oh jesus let's see what else let's see
what else this [ __ ] says here about you
uh it required the same from us for me
from my team we had to be equally
prepared and equally protective of the
interest that matt is the prepared part
that he that he had to be um is the same
thing as you right ghost writing for
trump is that him being no i'm working
on you right now monk mike pompeo
he he needed
no coaching
he came here and he said i will tell
this is what i want to say and i said
this is great you are genius you say
exactly what i think in brain we are
simpatico
simpatico huh yes we are one we are
linked you and me pompeo putin and
pompeo 2024 huh how does that sound
and where russia
wherever the world
the world so you're going to be the
you're going to be the dictator of the
world putin will rule the world
right so you want world war iii we got
it so let me ask you before we go
because i think this is a very important
question
is this
between between your three boyfriends
here because it really does seem like
you have three boyfriends very very good
loyal boyfriends and they're friends of
mine well right yeah they're definitely
friends of yours uh
you [ __ ] uh do you
what'd you say i said i said they are
very good friends of you oh yes very
good friends boyfriends we like to [ __ ]
up please found it out yeah you you fist
each other for sure uh between mike
pompeo donald trump yes and and also
also tucker carlson
which which one do you like the best
which one would you want to date long
term
they you mean like go to movies have
dinner have drinks
you have ice rink and ski and you have
these things in russia where you can
choose to do these things everyone has
access because they are not me
but i decide what people want and what
they don't want but if i were to say who
i would rather date and go do these
things with it would be um tucker
carlson is very good why why tucker why
tucker
because he has very soft skin
you know he's he reminds me of the putin
skin you know it's like let me put a
lotion on the skin and then he said
later when you come to russia
that is uh
tucker carlson then it would become
two too soft skin bros hanging out going
to see a movie going to enjoy the the
con the concert and uh and skiing on the
slopes you know like two bros two bros
huh well i i appreciate you stopping by
i'm glad our executive producer gabe
booked you to come on to the show i i'm
really sorry that you thought it was
tony montana show because it's not and
uh thanks for half-ass answering our
questions i guess um and really showing
how you're uh because i have one more
thing to say and go ahead
okay all right thanks a lot we really do
appreciate it uh bladdy daddy come here
and fisting and give fellatio
um as pompeo
the former guy
and tucker carlson give felicia
to him as he yeah yeah
okay yeah i'll shut your mic off
[ __ ] you goodbye putin uh
see you in l
okay everybody let's uh let's go to a
break and we'll be right back after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
vladimir putin coming on confirming
that he fist with tucker carlson i don't
think that's a big surprise to many
people
i don't think that's a big surprise to
many people let's get back to the
shitless round up here where we round up
all the tweety tweets and trinity trends
uh greg abbott has worked his way up to
number two quick fast and in a [ __ ]
hurry let's see why it's probably some
bigoted ass [ __ ] texas governor greg
abbott directs the state department of
family protection services to con
conduct investigations into gender
affirming care for change gender excuse
me transgender children on tuesday
okay well we have greg abbott um joining
in the the what appears to be the don't
say gay
train
they're terrified
of other people's genitalia and other
people's sexual identity they can't stop
talking about it
look these people who who identify as
lgbtq
they they really don't go around like
talking about their sexual identity they
they really don't they don't want you
asking about their genitalia or are
concerned about their genitalia they
really don't want you greg abbott
concerned about who they love who they
don't love that's the whole [ __ ]
point
that's old point they don't want you
[ __ ] concerned about it no
no one wants you in their love life
greg abbott
investigating some cr transgender
children
children
children
it looks like uh in this washington post
art article texas oh this is axios here
i don't know how we got to that
they do do
well here's the axios article texas
governor greg abbott today ordered state
agencies to investigate investigate
gender affirming care for transgender ki
transgender kids
as child abuse
uh so they're they're trying what
they're trying to say
and greg abbott is trying to say is that
parents
who are giving their children space
uh for gender affirming care
is child abuse
again they're targeting children here uh
just like the don't say gay bill
in florida is targeting children they
don't want them to say gay but if they
say they're gay they out them
to their parents and to the public
uh let's see
people are saying he's a [ __ ] monster
and they're all [ __ ] monsters this is
what you get when you elect a gqp this
is what you get
natalie here says fascism this is
fascism greg abbott is a fascist thank
you
thank you very much
and we should be against fascism a
hundred percent against it
aaron trail mom has the uh the statement
here
from this [ __ ] uh great gabbat has
officially directed family and
protection services to begin
investigating all trans children
that's the real key here
investigate all trans children
do you see how this you see how this
sounds [ __ ] familiar
you see how it sounds familiar
we're a [ __ ] who has executive
power over a government over police
force
over investigative body
would start to investigate a certain
group of people
because of who they are
because they're the other
they just can't be tolerated
well we should not tolerate the
intolerant and
investigating all trans children in
texas and prosecuting their parents
as child abusers
he also he has also instructed all
teachers doctors and caregivers to begin
reporting all trans students they see
begin reporting a narc list
huh
you know where else we see narc list in
the history
in the history of fascism you know where
else
you [ __ ]
i thank you aaron for posting this
statement
you read it you get credit here on the
shitless roundup
what a piece of [ __ ] trash greg
abbott is
let's see what else we have here uh
and kevin mchale says greg abbott can go
[ __ ] himself
uh i don't even greg abbott is so
unfuckable i don't even know if he would
[ __ ] himself but we'll retweet kevin
here uh let's see
of course this letter is circulating
fast
because they're
[ __ ] fascist bigots
uh mayo makes it pretty
clear here
greg abbott can [ __ ] off yeah i believe
that's a
i believe that's the truth he can just
[ __ ] right the hell off all the way like
all all the way
all the way off he can [ __ ]
okay let's see
um
cadet politic
politic ditto says
greg abbott's texas where it's a crime
to change your gender but changing your
patriotic loyalty is a okay
oh you want to support murderous
dictators you want to be a treasonous
benedict arnold [ __ ] that's cool
but try to try to consider changing your
gender nope
nope
to the gas chambers to you that's next
that's next i was talking to a teacher
friend of mine yesterday
and we're talking about the don't say
gay bill
in florida
and i said you know the
the progression here of this type of
fascism
on the others the other people they're
our problem the problem class of people
the monsters
the one denigrating our society
children they're [ __ ]
children
these aren't adults
that we're talking about here they're
going
after
children
they're targeting
children
that may or may not
want to be a different gender
you don't think the next progression
is to not just investigate
and round up the parents
where are the kids gonna go when they
round up the parents huh
where are they gonna go where are they
gonna put them
then what will they do with them once
they're housing them and i don't know
like a camp somewhere
you see the progression here
do you [ __ ] see the writing on the wall
out there who are saying oh well you're
overblowing this fascism thing this
fascism thing oh god tony you're just
overdoing it you're overstating it it's
not really fascism it's not nazi germany
no [ __ ] way
no way just because people show up at q
anon events the trucker rallies the
january 6 insurrection just because they
show up at those events with nazi flags
and nazi memorabilia
it mean that they're actually nazis that
let's go brandon phrase that's not a
nazi phrase
that has nothing to do with nazis trust
me
here you have it here you have it
greg abbott just can't leave children
alone look
they were bitching about education and
crt
for [ __ ] months months glenn younkin
ran on it
and one in virginia critical race theory
that scary voodoo
where they're gonna teach your children
guess what
guess what now it's now it's children
want different genitals bad that's the
new crt
how many how many school board meetings
do you think we're gonna see the clips
videos of people yelling and screaming
about transgender children
demeaning them being vile
discriminating against them wanting to
discriminate against them you don't
think someone's gonna say this [ __ ] i
remember back and i remember back and i
don't remember the pastor's name
unfortunately and i should go look it up
but someone can probably find it out
there
during the 2012 campaign where mitt
romney was running against barack obama
there was a pastor who went to iowa they
were holding some kind of [ __ ] stupid
christian event
he said on stage that the bible and
jesus and god wants us to execute gays
and transgender people
he said it on stage i'm not making this
[ __ ] up set it go look it up go google
it find the [ __ ] name
they're there he was projecting it all
the way back then
but he didn't he wasn't in power he
wasn't in government power he didn't
have the [ __ ] the puppet strings of
greg abbott and ron desantis they do now
they [ __ ] do now they definitely have
the puppet strings
to control these
fascists
to have a fascist state
jerry here says now more than ever
texans need greg abbott and his cronies
out of
office
we must vote them all out
every last [ __ ] one of these fascists
we have to vote them out
are they gonna come after your children
you think they're gonna stop at trans
kids
do you think they're gonna stop at the
parents of trans kids
do you think they'll stop there
what about what about when when oh
there's there's a liberal kid he's a
liberal in in alba he has all kinds of
liberal these we better investigate we
better investigate why he has those
liberal ideas maybe we should go round
up his parents
maybe we should go put them in a
concentration camp
you think they'll stop there
you think they'll stop there with those
children [ __ ] no they're not gonna stop
there with those children
hell to the no
that's what this is this is a slow walk
to a fascist state
this is the signs clear-cut right out in
the open they're not [ __ ] being quiet
about it anymore that [ __ ] bathroom
bill [ __ ] that was a couple years ago
and that was that was old token now you
know that was uh you have to prove you
know you have to have some kind of
verification that you're going in the
correct bathroom right
as if anyone gives a [ __ ] any non weirdo
gives a [ __ ] about what other people's
genitalia you are in the bathroom
do you do you go into the bathroom
thinking oh man this person next to me
their genitalia i wonder what it is
no only weirdos [ __ ] do that
you [ __ ] weirdos
why are you [ __ ] so concentrated on
someone else's genitalia and their
children's genitalia
greg abbott really does seem to be
[ __ ] obsessed here
with other people's children's genitalia
you notice that
you notice that hmm
pointing that out
i don't know stay fixed what are you
gonna do
these are the this is the [ __ ] that they
give us to talk about
i don't make this [ __ ] up
i don't [ __ ] force greg abbott to
[ __ ] discriminate against children
a certain group of children
i don't tell him to get his
guests gazpacho
his gazpacho his soup police
his soup nazis down in texas to
investigate children
because of who they think they are think
about that think about that
greg abbott that [ __ ] nazi
is telling his investigators
at his state agencies
to go investigate children
who
have an i different idea of who they
think they are than of what greg abbott
wants them to be
and not only are you going to punish
those children you're going to punish
the parents of those children and all
the other children that are in that
family
punish them
by using state force big government
this really does sound conservative
doesn't it no [ __ ] these guys
okay let's let's see here's a here
appears to be a clip of this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] talking about this let's
listen in on this vile piece of garbage
texas parents and even doctors could
face abuse investigations if they
provide health care options to
transgender children today governor greg
abbott sent a letter to the texas
department of family and protective
services directing the agency to look
into transgender care as child abuse
this letter follows a legal opinion
issued last week by attorney general ken
paxton he said his reading of texas law
shows this kind of care constitutes
child abuse advocates for the lgbtq
community in texas you wanna you wanna
know um what kind of regimes
tell you
how you raise your children
right
they tell you that your children can't
think a certain way
they can't think this way we don't want
them to think this way so they can't
think this way
they can't
you know they can't have all these
feelings inside of them these ideas
otherwise we might have to do something
about it
you [ __ ] gross mother this is [ __ ]
gross
really
really [ __ ] gross
and i applaud all people in texas don't
you gotta stay pissed
and this is why because they're gonna
slow walk to a fascist state and they'll
do it county by county school district
by school district state by state if
they have to
they are not going to stop they are not
going to relent these fascists are all
in on fascism that's what they want
that's what they're going to do that's
what they're going to try for that's
their aim
that's how they that's how they want it
they want a fascist state that's what
they want
and they're gonna get it by any means
necessary
even if it means starting with children
and
no more than being completely
obviously obsessed
with children's genitalia you [ __ ]
all right let's
greg abbott stewart and number three
gross [ __ ] okay
uh the hashtag protect
trans kids is now trending because we
should
we should protect all kids trans
straight
but especially protect the ones
that are being come they they are they
are after
by the fascist
they are going to round up parents and
children are you listening they're going
to investigate and round them up
what do you what do you think what do
you think is going to happen what the
[ __ ] you think is going to happen when
they decide that this parent and this
kid
we're gonna round them up we're gonna
arrest them we're gonna charge them now
the kid's gonna go to this home well
what happens to the other one two three
kids that are in that family where the
[ __ ] do they go huh where do they go you
gonna round them up too
just because their brother their sister
has a certain idea as a certain identity
that they want to identify as
these are [ __ ]
children
it's really [ __ ] gross
so go to the hashtag
and use that today protect trans kids
the other day it was don't say gay for
the florida bill you notice that florida
and texas are like
really trying to outdo out fascist each
other you notice that they're like
trying to they're like in a nazi
competition
right
desantis is like ah you can't say gay
and if you do we'll turn you in and
investigate you
and greg abbott's like hold my beer
[ __ ] we're just gonna round up the
parents and round up the children that's
what we'll do
you you say the word trans bam
round it up
[ __ ]
okay uh thanks john biden is still
trending let's see what we had on the
list
uh
had thanksgiving keystone oh yeah that's
that's right i wanna i wanna and
keystone
i wanna show you something here
i wanna show you um the [ __ ] uh
really boneheaded tweet
about the keystone pipeline because
keystone was trending earlier because
the gas prices and they think the
keystone xl pipeline is shut down that's
why gas prices high they're really
[ __ ] dumb uh leslie here responds
to [ __ ] bobo who says if joe biden
was serious about strengthening our
position against russia which this is
first off
he is strengthening our position against
russia he and the nato allies are the
only political party in this country
that are for the american side
therefore
they're they're for
america they're supporting the american
cause
joe biden
serious about get the [ __ ] out here she
says
he'd reopen the key
the keystone xl
so if joe biden was really serious
about strengthening his position against
russia
because you know this pipeline thing
that's happening over in germany again
that pipeline isn't open
neither was the keystone xl pipeline
and get america energy back up and
running
the keystone xl pipeline isn't it wasn't
running
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't running
and joe biden turned the faucet off
number one even if you got even if joe
biden was like okay
lauren beaubert has a really stupid
[ __ ] point here but let's play ball
and he opens the key
keystone xl pipeline he does that we're
not going to see that oil
that oil is not stopping in america
it's going through america that's what
the pipeline is
it's to go from canada to the gulf it's
not it's not to stop
in colorado you dumb [ __ ]
there's not like a [ __ ] faucet in
colorado that you're gonna walk up to
and just get you some crude out of
bobert [ __ ] idiot
that's a really [ __ ] stupid tweet
by the way your tweet sucks
it's a really horrible tweet
you trunt
okay
uh
leslie says the keystone was never open
because it was never built also
no
oh thank you leslie yes
that's great
that's great okay let's go back to this
so we gotta have a lot of people
trolling this idiot
and let's see you did it
of course everyone's like please open
the keystone pipeline it'll solve all of
our russian problems
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
gas price is high because biden
well i mean if it's russian's fault
bobert if it really is russia's fault
that the gas prices are high
if that's the thing then why are you
blaming it on biden
why
why are you blaming on biden here we go
here's another [ __ ] bonehead
and the the the governor
of south dakota here in this in this uh
what's her what's her face christy gnome
and
let's listen to this idiot well that's
the power that president biden gave them
when he canceled the keystone pipeline
on day one of his presidency he sent a
clear message to putin you go ahead
develop your energy supply
make sure that the rest of europe and
the united states is more unstable he
from the very day
he got into the white house he gave
putin all the power this is more
[ __ ] more [ __ ] dribble
that's not
the keystone xl pipeline is not gonna
stop in america it's not gonna give
america [ __ ] oil it's not gonna give
america gasoline
canada is trying to sell it and they're
using us as the highway to get it to the
place that they want to sell it
that's all it is
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
ron posted this he says the foreign
policy genius
i'm sure he's being sarcastic here that
his christie gnome claims that biden
caused russia to invade ukraine when he
canceled permits to expand the keystone
pipeline from alberta
canada to nebraska from the very day he
got into the white house he gave putin
all the power
this is really donated [ __ ]
really [ __ ] boneheaded [ __ ]
thanks for keeping the clips coming run
okay let's see here
let's go back to the trendy trends
there's a lot of stuff going here i
don't want to miss anything let's see
what else do we have on the list today
oh this martin hyde that's right he must
have dropped off the list a lot of [ __ ]
going on uh let's find this guy's thread
i want to show you the video of this guy
[Music]
yep there's the guy
and there's the let's see where's the
video
here's the video here ron's got the
video of course ron's got the video so
let's do this let's go to a break when
we come back
we'll play ron's video and talk about
who the [ __ ] this
martin hyde is
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopes mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the troop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop left you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging with us through the
break
we're gonna go ahead and show you who
this uh
this uh what's his name what's his
martin hyde
and how he got stopped if i can get the
the video to go here
okay here we go okay let's let's play
this this is this is a congressional
candidate
white dude white old ball sack right as
we like to call him here wrinkly old
white ball sack
and he's gonna he's gonna i don't know
he's gonna he's gonna say something to
this officer he gets real smart he's
nice at first notice and then he turns
hi how are you doing are you doing sarah
sebastian sarasota police department on
audio and video recording the reason for
the stop you were observed going 57 and
a 40 and you were on your phone texting
while you were doing that
that was at euclid and fruitville
oh [ __ ] she challenged him
[Laughter]
why do you old white dudes don't like
that don't you know that lady and it
doesn't matter if you're a cop or not
especially if you're if you're if you're
a lady in your cap he definitely doesn't
like to be told like that
don't you know this don't you know this
and you're supposed to treat him with
the utmost respect because he's white
and he's old and he's got a sweaty old
ballsack
i'm not pointing at you i'm pointing in
the direction where it was just
go right ahead sir i want my i want you
to see but he does that i want to see
your manager like almost right off the
bat
the [ __ ] karen here wants to see the
manager uh like she just she tells him
the citation and she pulled him over for
like you were speeding and you were
texting [ __ ] i pulled you over
and he's like i want to see your manager
can i see you
yes sir i do you know who i am right
who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ]
can i see your last registration
insurance please did you do this
yes sir
you gonna do this it sounds like a
threat doesn't it can you imagine can
you imagine if you pulled over like a i
don't know you know
18 19 year old black man
can you imagine he comes up to the car
cop says
pulled you over for speeding and texting
and he had this smart [ __ ] mouth on
him you know who i am you know who i am
you gonna do this you're gonna do this
i wonder what would happen i wonder if
we have video of similar instances
here we go
i'm sorry
i don't have a job by the way look at it
look at this
why why do all these [ __ ] have the the
trump bill o'reilly chin right it's got
the the chin and then the [ __ ]
rooster flap
right
why do they all have that that that
mangina chin
that
what is that that the chest the
chinnicles
you know
i don't know what is that that just
seems it seems [ __ ]
common with these [ __ ] [ __ ]
still have a job to do sir yeah
how long have you now he's interviewing
her
now he's interviewing her how long you
been in the department what's your name
what's your name are you lying you know
he's trying to do here because he knows
you on camera because she says at first
he's on camera he knows this so he's
trying to do the whole sovereign citizen
you know where they pull you over and
you tell them to go [ __ ] themselves
thing where you rolled the window down
like this which you can do by the way
you can absolutely you absolutely have
the right to treat a cop like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you have the right to do that you
you have the complete right to do that
you can treat them like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can be a [ __ ] [ __ ] it is your
right to be an [ __ ] in this country
it is your right to be an [ __ ] now
everyone knows you're an [ __ ]
especially when you get pulled there
you're like where's your manager i want
your [ __ ] manager what's your name
how long you've been working here
you know same old [ __ ] you go in you go
in there
they're pissed off about something that
they ordered at the fast food joint they
want to see the manager almost
immediately
and then they're [ __ ] they're worried
about how long you worked here
[ __ ]
sir can i have it
seven years sir
can i see our registration please
no
no can you can you even
can you even think about how this video
go if it was a black dude no
nope [ __ ] you nope not gonna do it not
gonna do it
not gonna do it it's against my hipaa
i'm not showing you my registration it's
against my hipaa laws
i mean same [ __ ] i'd go see a manager
against my hipaa laws same [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
you're not going to give me a
registration sir can you harass me
i'm asking you if you're going to are
you going to arrest me
ah [ __ ] this guy this [ __ ] guy this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] ball ginny and gay
i'm serious look at this look at this
look they all have that [ __ ] thing
i'm not lying am i i'm not i'm not at
i'm not imagining things am i they all
have the [ __ ]
that they all have the [ __ ] the balls
underneath the chin
trump's got it mcconnell's got it
bill o'reilly's got they all got it
tucker's probably growing one
right
and a [ __ ] pompeo his is really
flabby now because he you know he lost
all that weight so it's like a really
[ __ ] flappy ball sack underneath his
chin what the [ __ ] is that what is that
what the [ __ ] is that i'm just asking
you know some people might want to know
you're not gonna give me a registration
sir can you arrest me
i'm asking you if you're gonna produce
me with your registration
you don't have it on you
look
goku
tell him how good you just feel
blame this video
okay
can you call the mayor okay
ron post
mike blandon roger stone back
congressional candidate like that's all
you need like you know you need to go
any further you know you write anymore
[ __ ] just that dot dot dot that's what i
would have wrote
like all right here you go here's your
video everybody it's mike flynn and
roger stone back congressional candidate
dot dot dot that's all you need to know
you don't need another [ __ ] you
don't need to just watch the video and
know that it's backed by mike glenn and
roger stone which you can already tell
that from the [ __ ] video
you don't need you don't need someone to
tell you that he's backed by these
[ __ ] [ __ ] bags to know that he's
backed by these [ __ ] bags of course he
is
not backing the blue
in the new traffic stop
yeah he really he really does not back
the blue i mean you know he does
if they're you know
white male fascist with the with the
ball sack maybe that's what it is maybe
that's what it is it's like they're you
know their uniform they go have this
done have the
the ball sack underneath the chin done i
don't know i'm just saying it seems kind
of weird they all got that
i'll just call your chief
he says you know who i am right
you're going to do this
big mistake
get me your manager
you're making career decisions right now
as you speak
as you talk to me because i'm powerful
white man with a balchinian
that the mitch mcconnell donald trump
balchinian rudy's got it too doesn't he
doesn't rudy have one of those uh
done rudyard
i'm just i'm just thinking of people who
got this thing bill o'reilly's got one
just
snowballing here nah thanks ron for your
tweet
for posting this about this guy giving
him his [ __ ] five seconds of fame
more importantly more importantly anyone
out there that's gonna go vote in this
guy's district go vote against this
[ __ ] now get registered get
registered so this guy is not
representing you anywhere
not for
congress not for [ __ ] city council
not for the county commissioner not for
[ __ ] dog catcher [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
him and anyone who looks like him him
and his balchinian okay uh
let's see if there's any more yeah it's
just a video right
it's just the video oh is this the guy
is this the guy same guy the [ __ ] joe
biden
someone was saying that there was a
banner or something fuller gop candidate
and self-important bully martin hyde
pulls the old do you know who i am stunt
just another trump obsessed [ __ ] than
her mints
when will florida wise up um it's going
to end your career someone is saying
there's a the [ __ ] joe biden
uh banner on a balcony i guess this is
maybe it his hoa is pissed off or
something i guess
yeah his his hoa is pissed off i don't
know you know this [ __ ] guy
do come on there we go
computer's running slow today
it's running slow
okay
oh here's here we go this is from
february 15th this is congressional
candidate martin hyde ron's all over
this [ __ ] let's see let's
let's hear what this guy has to say i'm
sure it's just riveting here good
evening my name
is martin hyde and for those of you that
are constitutionally illiterate all
amendments are absolute unless you can
get three quarters of the state
to ratify a change so forget that you're
supposed to be in education actually
talk about the truth first off let me
say there are 10
10 armed police here 10. we had six
shootings in sarasota over the last two
months and yet you've got 10 cops here
for a room full of parents
wake up and smell the roses mr edwards
bless your heart my card was in third
that you he really he really is get this
obsession about the police
it seems
it seems he's
jesus
couldn't get it in the right order and
it just happened to be coincidentally
after i told you off last week i don't
know what to tell you passive aggressive
doesn't work try aggressive like all the
big guys
education
is a weapon
whose effects often depend on who holds
it in his hands and at whom it is aimed
it's a quote from stalin
another quote
give me four years to teach the children
and the seed i've sown will never be
uprooted
that was said in many occasions in
different formats by lenin
one of the main history lessons that we
know history always repeats itself
the reason i come here and mr edwards
i will continue to come here
is to stop the three of you attempting
to indoctrinate our county's kids into
your cult of woke
yeah jesus these the [ __ ] the woke
mob [ __ ]
is [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] where history is
woke like yeah so we just [ __ ] see
the wokeness
of history like facts and [ __ ]
yeah woke okay
uh i got a link here
and i'm gonna
i'm gonna put it in here let's see
come on there we go
sorry there we go
speaking of ball chin ins
we may have a uh a video here let's just
see what's going on working 24 hours a
day just about he has been working very
very hard very diligently
and very professionally and i want to
thank him i've been working that's
that's really [ __ ] gross
it's really [ __ ] gross
ball
i mean maybe you got another name for it
it may look like oh it may look like
another
type of genitalia who knows who can tell
who can tell at these this point with
these [ __ ]
okay
let's go back to tweet tweets and trendy
trends
uh no covet is trending and for you
thanks joe biden still trending uh bret
hart is trending
it's just a wrestler
[Music]
earlier ukraine
the
president of ukraine is telling people
to get the [ __ ] out of russia
get the [ __ ] out of russia where is it
[Music]
see if we can find it
the ukrainian president
is telling people to leave
russia
russian
[Music]
uh
here's another story uk defense
secretary ben wallace tells russian
president vladimir putin
has gone
full tanto while discussing the latest
escalation ukraine with military
personnel on wednesday
uh
let's see
that's not that that's not that's not
the story i'm looking for here
what i'm looking for is the is the story
about the ukrainian president
um
saying hey hey you need to get the hell
out of russia i think that's probably
important uh
the ukrainian president address maybe
that's where it's at
um
crisis
um
sorry i'm i'm looking for and let's
let's go to this thread
let's go to this thread let's go this
thread about the ukrainian president i
think uh
maybe we'll find some stuff we're
looking for here ukraine president addre
presidential address
new york times is reporting
uh ukraine is not afraid of anything
president zielinski said in the national
address he called for international
support as vladimir putin ordered
russian troops
to two break away regions in ukraine
ukraine is behind me within the
international recognized borders and it
will remain so despite any statements
and actions of the russian federation um
so zielinski gives an address to the
world uh and to ukraine
making sure that uh his
his stance is clear that he's not gonna
back away from putin here and just let
putin take ukraine
i think that's probably a pretty
significant thing and here's why is that
that putin you know he took georgia he
took crimea not much effort on pushback
a little bit not much
um and the reason why this is such a big
deal is because vladimir putin is
testing president joe biden and thanks
joe biden
for having some [ __ ] nuts to stand up
to vladimir putin and tell him no no
you're not going to do this you can't do
this [ __ ] i don't think so
lincoln watchman here has a picture it
says president biden to address the
ongoing oh this was yesterday
uh he was waiting for someone i'll go
ahead and retweet lincoln watchman there
give him credit
uh expected to announce
a new round of sanctions
uh i don't the problem is i don't think
financial sanctions are really gonna
force putin's hand here um he's probably
got a lot of stuff kiddied away and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] we heard him you
heard him talk earlier he didn't give a
[ __ ]
it's about him and only him he doesn't
care about the russian people you know
they're supposed to think he's god and
[ __ ]
uh
let's see
uh this was yesterday i'm looking for
the statement uh from the president of
ukraine
to
ukraine president there we go let's just
see if we can get it with that
did it did do
what i want to see the statement from
the president ukraine where he tells
he's telling the uh ukrainian people
that are in russia get the [ __ ] out of
russia
uh get the [ __ ] out of russia
shit's about to go down
uh
i think i think putin is a little
miscalculated here i mean um you know
he's going to do what he's going to do
and he's going to do what he thinks he's
got to do here
uh but
dude
it's not going to be go well for him i
don't think not much goes well with
putin
when he fights democracy it just does
not
it just does not we heard him earlier we
heard him earlier right here on the tony
michael's show not the tony montana show
the tony michael show
uh let's see
i'm trying to find sorry
traders to democracy is trending again
oh let's go on after it i like that
thread let's go in that thread oh
picking putin over america makes you
traders democracy that's a good one uh
traders to democracy
they are for sure for sure
let's go back let's see
is there anything trending greg abbott's
back up to number two
snowfall proud family thanks joe biden's
number 10 still because they don't know
that they can buy a different vehicle
then
then
they're big ass uh
little dick energy trucks
uh let's see
no covet what is this
what is this trending no covid
no kovet is this like they they think
that there's no covet left
no coveted passports face mask
no covet i don't know
oh
no covet can do kind of damage this man
in america
what the [ __ ] oh well let's see what
what is this
you seen the clip of marjory taylor
green on this guy's show the other day
saying they call me crazy it bothers me
it bothers me that they call me crazy he
went she went on his show this guy's
show and i'm not even bitching i'm
trying to understand why i'm the worst
communicator
worse go better job
what the [ __ ] your ass together now
i'm serious i suck
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
freaking killing everybody everybody's
in a trance
what what
is this about the [ __ ]
trails
i'm serious man i'm two inches folks
from walking out here forever can't do
this anymore man
oh god damn when was this too bad we
didn't push him over the edge this must
have been a while back and he's still
going as [ __ ] we're in a damn war
they're murdering everybody
it's funny
well i don't think it's funny
ah you're [ __ ] you are [ __ ] out of
your mind and marjorie taylor green goes
on this guy's show this guy's show and
says i don't know why they think i'm
[ __ ] crazy i have no idea these
people think i'm crazy
these people they think i'm [ __ ] nuts
how could i be so nuts i can't be nuts
i mean look at you you're reasonable
look at you alex jones you're completely
what the [ __ ]
good lord
this is what they like though
this is the [ __ ] they got and that's
under no kobe because it says no kobe
can do this kind of damage
that this man has done to america over
the past 20 plus years
yeah he's been doing it to america all
right can you believe that this guy
became mainstream donald trump did that
to this guy literally i mean you know
every every everyone who knows about
white right-wing freaks and these
[ __ ] these [ __ ] maniacs knows who
alex jones is but the but the real thing
is is that most americans if you said
who's alex jones they wouldn't have
known they wouldn't have no [ __ ] idea
no [ __ ] clue what infowars or alex
jones is no clue
i mean yeah a certain percentage of the
population and it's a lot of people
that's the kind of the problem is
there's a lot of people you know low
percentage of the population a lot of
people like in numbers
wise that keeps this guy going because
they buy all his [ __ ] his snake oils
you know his supplements and [ __ ]
all the stuff he sells hawks on the show
and most of it's supplements most of
it's like literal snake oil
that he sells on his show you know
support him financially here
but she's he's possibly going to lose
that battle with the battle that he lost
with the
the families of sandy hook but anyways i
digress from that
donald trump made this guy mainstream to
where everyone knows who this guy is
it's a problem that's a real [ __ ]
problem that people
not only know this guy's like yeah i
listen to him he's got a lot of hot
takes
he thinks there's lizard people there's
frog [ __ ] in the water and he thinks
there's chemtrails
you know fluoride frog [ __ ] i don't know
what they think i don't know something
about frog [ __ ] or something right i
don't know you got me
you got me i don't know i don't
know
i don't know if it's frog [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
i don't know they think something crazy
he thinks kin turtles are like
brainwashing people or some [ __ ] doesn't
he anything that's gonna like turn
people into lizard people fluoride
fluoride in the water is gonna kill
people or turn them into lizard people
fluoride
yeah just it just make sure your teeth
don't decay
yeah [ __ ] bonehead
and of course marjorie taylor green
loves this guy goes on the show i don't
know why they think i'm crazy i'm on
your show
there's nothing crazy about that all
right let's go one more time back to
where we're 10 minutes before the top of
the hour here
we're uh
50 minutes into the second hour remember
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
twitch
you can see us the tony michaels podcast
we interview people great people like
vladimir putin you just seen vlady daddy
on
on the podcast gabe booked that
interview for us by the way i think
that's how i'm going to work from now
gabe booked that interview for us with
vladimir putin so go go
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel if you're late coming to the
podcast
because you're definitely going to want
to watch
that video of laddie daddy and speaking
of interviews
tomorrow we're going to air
the interview with high fidelity from
radicalized podcast
where he talks about this
go of the ottawa truckers and it's all
in the lead up to this dc thing because
i would imagine they're going to have a
gibson go with that and i would imagine
they're still the same type of russian i
mean uh suspicious stuff suspicious
stuff that could happen on those records
so come watch tomorrow that'll be almost
the whole show tomorrow because it is a
really long piece of material we did a
lot of work on that uh other interviews
this week that we had we had salman
bojani from texas 92nd he's on that's a
great interview so go watch that one um
i think i think we might have rachel
bitkoffer on on friday
everyone like loves rachel here she's a
political strategist with strike pack
she gives us all her good insight into
strategic outrage but i think she's got
some news for us maybe the other thing i
want to ask her about the other thing i
really want to ask her about is this
cpac thing the cpac thing you know i
want to ask rachel i want to ask her
rachel
why don't democrats have these big
circle jerk events we should we should
have those everyone's like oh tony you
can't say that yeah i can have democrats
need to have a big circle jerkman just
like the republicans do it works it
[ __ ] works it gets people riled up it
gets people know the message it's
messaging that's what it is
we need to have maybe it's a d-pack i
don't know that sounds kind of yeah
and circle jerk d-pack and you're
getting in uh
wild territory there but we should have
our own we should have our own [ __ ]
events our own big events where all of
all of the crazy left wingers all of us
radical socialists you know people who
want decent health care who want a
decent [ __ ] wage who don't want to go
bankrupt because of medical bill who
want their kids to start school at three
instead of five you know radical ass
[ __ ] like that radical stuff like that
make sure you can retire on social
security and if you can't
companies provide 401ks in retirement
for you radical [ __ ] like that
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
people want to be educated they don't
want to go bankrupt because of health
care they actually want some health care
too
like they want it they don't want to get
sick
and and they they they just don't want
to go broke they want a decent [ __ ]
wage that's what they want that's like
the american dream right
that's the american dream
for most
for most people that is the american
dream just to have those that small
sense of security
you [ __ ]
radical so we should have our own
radical socialist
circle jerk event just like the seat
back we should have one and that way we
can get the messaging out to more and
more people it pumps the message out to
the public that's what it does that's
the design that's the design of the cpac
uh the seat pack is to get that message
out
because it does because they go say wild
and crazy [ __ ] on stage and we're like
jesus christ he's [ __ ] nazis look at
these [ __ ] nazis and then we gotta
play the [ __ ] nazi [ __ ] we gotta
explain violence nazi [ __ ] to people
because they're gonna see it people are
gonna see the nazi [ __ ] then you have to
break down why it's the nazi [ __ ] you
can't ignore it you got sunlight is the
best disinfectant always you always have
to disinfect these people with sunlight
that's the way it works for 53 minutes
in the hour don't forget tomorrow
again we're gonna have a great interview
with high fidelity
here on the tony michaels podcast let's
go ahead and play a clip
from that from that interview so you
guys know what's coming tomorrow
so i looked at email address to zip code
first name last name to email address
email address to credit card type
this is what i found man over 2 000
email addresses appear twice what the
[ __ ]
204 appear three times
46 before and you can see the numbers
right right right right there is one
email address that appears 16 [ __ ]
times now wait a second wait a second
that seems that seems totally fine now
wait a second now wait no because
because if i wanted to if i wanted to
donate 16 times i might use my email
address the same email address each time
and that is absolutely fair and i
understand that and that is organic
right i did look through some of the
duplicates and i found there were some
people like i was able to identify
people and i'll show you that later on
there were organic multiple donations
right that's right what makes these
different well let me show you so what i
found here here was the first one i
looked at right and this was four
records so i have four donations i have
four different names
as you can see right there donation
first donation
you're saying the first and last name
are completely different on each one of
these as well on each one we have alyssa
jordan
richard and jerry
right okay it sounds like all of them
sounds like a whole family of them yeah
yeah except all of them have the same
email address
with four different zip codes what the
[ __ ]
ford
well so here's my thought right
maybe these emails are emails that have
somebody that will answer any questions
to that email but they're using that to
launder the donations to that email does
that make sense like hey i've got this
one
email the email is the contact point in
other words yeah yeah we don't have
phone numbers right right right so like
it's like if anything goes awry and they
need to respond
there's a person that might have the
email but there might be these tentacles
of donations that are tied back to that
and they're trying to
maybe they're trying to hide by
different zip codes and different names
of who actually has that email right you
look at this one there's three from the
united states there's one from canada
right i actually went out and found the
email address and i did find the email
address it's in japan
so
you see that there's suspicious stuff
happening over uh at the gibson go for
the ottawa truckers convoy and probably
gonna be the same [ __ ] for the dc
jerkers convoy now that they're they're
they're calling on the national guard to
make sure to protect the capital of the
united states and probably the
constitution and probably our government
these people want to have an
insurrection everywhere not just in
canada not just here they want to have
an insurrection on democracy everywhere
that's that's the thing they love they
love having an insurrection for
democracy that's what putin's doing over
in ukraine
democracy is not a tyrant's friend it
isn't he knows that he knows democracy
is not a tyrant's friend
he knows it
so come tomorrow and watch that
interview with high fidelity of
radicalized pod go follow him on on
twitter radicalizepod
we had his co-host on heidi kuda uh a
while back i think in december is when
heidi came on if you go subscribe to the
youtube channel you can find that
interview as well heidi kuda from the
radicalized podcast she was on her show
in a very good interview with heidi too
um she talks about the her other co-host
jim stewartson's video where that outed
michael flynn to be a cult leader or
what he wants to be a cult leader so go
watch that interview don't miss it
tomorrow do not miss tomorrow also go
follow us on at toni michael's pod and
follow me at the tony michaels and gabe
i am gabe sanchez but follow at the tony
michael's pod for the bonehead of the
week poll i will probably put that out
today that way you can go ahead and vote
on it that way friday
friday we can do bone end of the week in
the second hour so the second hour we're
at bone in the week first hour we're
gonna have rachel bitkoffer on i think
talk about cpac talk about these
treasonous republicans and how good that
message is how how good the the pootie
message is the bloody daddy message we
love you bladdy daddy
we love you we'll see how good that
message is
for the republicans at least we'll get
rachel's opinion on how good that is for
the republicans so stay tuned stay tuned
tomorrow and stay tuned friday as well
as well
and until until tomorrow noon eastern 11
central like i said every single weekday
right here on youtube twitter twitch
until tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's mealborn head ass speaking